foreign
[Music]
everybody ready let's roll the cameras
and we are 1603
there we go 1576 a quiet life fair
enough all right E4
well we respond with the Sicilian
hopefully we finally get a main line now
we still aren't getting any main lines
Knight to C3 uh which is a move that we
faced once
um maybe like seven or eight games ago
and it was a suspicious opponent but uh
it does appear that my opponent in that
game might have been smurfing himself
but in any case we've already discussed
Knight C3 at length and to summarize
the basic
point about playing against Knight to C3
is that whichever line you play against
the open Sicilian you should play the
corresponding line against Knight C3 so
if you're a knight or player you should
play D6 if you're a
um powellson player or a taimana player
then you should play the move E6 so you
have to remember that on the next move
white can play Knight F3 and then D4 and
transpose the game back into an open
Sicilian so it's very easy if you're not
experienced to get what's called move
ordered into a line that you do not play
and I'll summarize that once again after
the game
now one really interesting move here
that I think is very underrated and it's
a move that you absolutely should
consider if you are an accelerated
Dragon player which for the purposes of
this speedrun we are this move obviates
a lot of the theory that goes along with
Knight C6 Bishop B5 which is what we
Face uh the first time around and this
is a move which does fly under the radar
and that's the immediate G6 this was
played against me uh by Vladimir fedes
my good friend who's now a very strong
Grand Master he played this against me
when we were both about 2300 and uh I
think it doesn't have too big of a
downside of course Bishop B5 in this
position makes absolutely no sense okay
so our opponent transposes into a great
or nothing transpose he plays the Grand
Prix attack and now we simply play uh
the same way that we would if we had
gone Knight C6 we feed and Cato our
Bishop
and I'm presuming that White's going to
play Knights F3 here and then we've we
put together we carry out a setup that
is considered to be uh the best way to
play against the Grand Prix attack and
this is also a setup that you can take
under consideration against the closed
Sicilian and the closed Sicilian and
Grand Prix attack are are in many ways
similar the chief difference between
them is that in the closed Sicilian
white generally fianchetto's the bishop
is a lot more positional in the Grand
Prix attack white goes for our throat by
deploying the bishop either immediately
or after a preliminary check on B5 to
the square C4 in order to attack the F7
Square the Grand Prix attack is a very
scary opening especially For Less
experienced players so if you're a
sicilian player who doesn't like facing
the Grand Prix watch this carefully and
then we will discuss the opening in
Greater length after the game so first
things first we simply need to develop
our pieces and it makes perfect sense to
start with the move Knight cc6 this is
the most flexible move we are not
committing thing to any particular pawn
moves just yet we are going to wait for
white to commit to a Bishop Square there
we go now we know more about white setup
so as far as I know
uh there is a good move in this position
for black that takes the sting out of a
lot of the sort of scary aspects of the
Grand Prix attack which you want to
avoid here you want to avoid the move E6
because if you play E6 then white takes
our Knight and then drives the pawn down
to E5 and creates a complex of dark
square holes on D6 and F6 and C5 and you
know I've won games like this before
from the other side so we don't want to
play E6 we certainly can play the move
D6 D6 is a very legitimate line but as
far as I know a good line here that
flies under the radar a little bit is
the immediate move Knight to D4 and
Knight to D4 is a response that you
should be sort of familiar with in
general from other openings in the
trumpowski you get this type of move
where the downside of putting the
Bishops on B5 and G5 is that they are
vulnerable to 94 or Knight D4 now
obviously this move offers a nitrate and
I like that our opponent is thinking
because I'm basically out of my own
Theory here we're going to do some
improvisation and then after the game
we're actually going to check the theory
Castle's short I think that's the right
move so white basically turns the tables
back on us and says if you want this
bishop go ahead and take it and guess
what we most certainly want that Bishop
because the light scored Bishop in the
Grand Prix attack is perhaps White's
main attacker when it positions itself
on C4 it puts tremendous pressure on the
F7 pawn and that Bishop uh is uh the
Bishop from hell in many Grand Prix
attack positions so we're just gonna get
rid of the bishop we're gonna trade
okay our opponent is thinking fair
enough Knight takes B5
okay I hope there were no Alternatives
there and now well we have another
dilemma
we have another dilemma a lot of people
I think would have the Instinct of
playing A6 right A6 is kind of an
instinctual reaction you have when you
see a knight on B5 but let me take the
opposite point of view which is to say
that first of all A6 we can keep for a
rainy day and second of all it's not
like the Knight on B5 is causing us any
imminent danger right it's not
threatening to go to C7 no it's
definitely not threatening to go to D7
and it's just kind of sitting there it's
pretty vulnerable it's undefended so I
think we should save the move A6 for a
little bit later in the game
particularly because after Asics the
Knight drops back to C3 where it clamps
down on the D5 Square now I don't think
we should go Queen B6 I don't think we
should go A6 I think we should leave
this Knight B for the time being and we
should instead work on completing our
King side development now if we go with
the immediate Knight F6 I don't like the
look of allowing E5 white kind of drives
that pawn into our position so what
we're going to start with is the move D6
we're going to start with D6 if you're a
sicilian player this is kind of a very
classic move uh we're occupying and
controlling some key Central squares and
on the next move we will be ready
finally to develop our night with or
without A6
uh D5 was bad D5 e takes D5 and then if
Queen takes D5 the Knight does in fact
access C7 okay D3 so now we continue our
development again I think a lot of
people would be tempted to play Bishop
D7 let's develop with Tempo but Bishop
on D7 is not a particularly noteworthy
piece and I still don't think that we
should help white go back to C3
so I like the look of Knight F6
there's also the move Knight H6 which
can sometimes be played in in these
types of lines but let's play more
conventionally in this game we're gonna
go Knight F6
I'm gonna go Knight F6
okay
yeah so you might be wondering if E5 is
dangerous here I don't think E5 is
dangerous
because I think we can just take on E5
and if white takes back we can go Knight
F6 to D5 kind of owl kind cell Queenie
won by our opponent playing very very
well our opponent is demonstrating
knowledge of all the right Grand Prix
attack ideas and this is kind of the
chief idea among them white wants to
play Queen H4 and then F5 and then
Bishop H6 and Knight G5 and there's a
bunch of these typical Grand Prix attack
moves that if black falls asleep on can
result in Rapid checkmate
so
let me think for a second this is
actually a pretty complicated position
I'm sure that this is still probably
within the confines of theory
my general approach here with black
would actually be to delay castling I
think castle and kingside allows the
king to become a Sitting Duck
and allows white to basically Focus all
of his efforts on checkmating us
so we have the idea of castling Queen
side that's totally not out of the
question but that's kind of hard to
organize right we still have the bishop
we still have the queen we have to move
both pieces if we want to Castle
queenside but I actually kind of do I
actually do want to try to Castle
queenside this is not a plan I have
tried often in the Grand Prix attack
so here's the thing if we play Bishop D7
white goes Knight C3 and then our Queen
doesn't have too many good squares if we
play Queen C7 in that position we're
already running into the move E5
so we need to be very careful about how
we position our Bishop I think a
superior way of getting this done is to
play Bishop to G4 but then what white
still has the move E5 and that looks
very very nasty
so geez
let me take a little bit more time here
and think
okay I think the complications work out
for us I think we can play Bishop G4
I think we can play Bishop G4
and develop our Bishop and prepare to
play Queen d8 to D7 hitting the Knight
and preparing to Castle queenside the
other good thing about Bishop G4 is that
we can basically take the Knight on F3
on demand
we can take the Knight on F3 on demand
now the move I had to calculate was E5
right E5 is the principled move that you
always have to consider in in these
types of Grand Prix positions
but I think after E5
we play Pawn takes Pawn white plays Pawn
takes Pawn
we swing our Knight over to D5 and the
move that caused concern at first was
Knight F3 to G5 hopefully you're still
visualizing but then I realized the the
blackened Castle King side and
simultaneously defend F7 and the line
goes on we'll talk about it after the
game but our opponent takes a different
path Queen H4 now we should continue
with our general strategy and I think we
should play the move Queen to D7
yeah I mean Castle in Queen said listen
are we out of the woods on the queen
side absolutely not I mean Castle in
queenside is pretty Brazen I will admit
in this position it is a very Brazen
concept but I want to try it I'm
actually a lot more comfortable on the
queen side than I am on the king side
because white is already amassed his
Queen right it's sitting on H4 and
saying you know I dare you I dare you to
Castle kingside you know I'm not a
betting man let's let's go the other way
let's go the other way we can take the
Knight first
and that might be sensible
because if we Castle queenside
immediately white has this weird looking
move Knight F3 to G5 and if you think
about it that Bishop on G4 is in a fair
bit of trouble white will be threading
H3 in that position so I actually think
we should eliminate the Knight first
and then we should castle queenside and
I will admit it I wouldn't say that I've
been outplayed but I definitely would
prefer white here I think white is
better
I think white is better but our position
is fundamentally sound and now we go
Queen side let's get the heck out of the
range of the queen
peculiar state says I really don't like
Bishop takes F3 but hopefully you
understood the logic I also uh in theory
do not love the idea of giving up my
light skirt Bishop we want to keep the
bishop pair if possible
but there was a specific concern with
the immediate castles
okay so sometimes you just got to do
what you got to do
okay so what are what are gonna be what
is our road map here well there's like
two categories of moves there's moves
that we can play to just make small
improvements to our position and what is
like the typical move that you often
play after you Castle queenside who can
tell me this is like automatic in so
many different positions because it
because it improves the safety yeah King
B8 right you want to go King B8 uh
because the King on B8 is just safer
than it is on see it on C8 it's just you
know the C file is more likely to open
up on B8 it also guards the pawn on A7
and it just it can run over to A8 if uh
the necessity arises
so we can go King B8 what are some other
moves that just make small improvements
in our position well I'm thinking about
the movie H7 to H5 essentially
restricting the White Queen a little bit
and also creating a stronghold on G4 on
which we can plant well we can plant the
Knight there and start out some
attacking ideas with Bishop D4 or we can
put the queen on G4 and potentially
after a queen trade and notice that if
we play the move H5 and white responds
with H3 we can potentially still play
Knight G4
because after hghg it's like a fishing
pole idea The Rook on F3 will be hanging
and even if it's not hanging the open H
file might make it worth the sacrifice
so
I'm thinking about King B8 I'm thinking
about H5 I'm also thinking about the
idea of playing H6 and G5 to blast open
the G file let's not forget the whites
King it may seem totally safe for the
time being but if we can manage to open
up the G file we've got a lot of
material sitting there on the king side
waiting to attack the white king so it
is a double-edged position
it is a double-edged position the move
I'm kind of worried about I think a very
classy move for white not an easy move
for an intermediate player to play it's
not five our opponent takes the concrete
approach and plays E5 forces us to
calculate Let's Get Down a business
so let's calculate
well my instinct of course is to take
this Pawn because it essentially
isolates as a result upon an E5 so let's
calculate D5 fe5 what our options are
available for the night well we were
just talking about a particular square
that I think is the juiciest Square for
the night and that I think is the G4
Square D E F E Knight G4
White's probably gonna grab the pawn on
F7
and then as a result I actually have a
really cool idea there I don't know if
it's gonna work
does anybody see an option in that
position it is chaotic but you should
still see like a very tempting move
yeah so there's no Bishop D4 check but
at a minimum at a minimum
at an absolute minimum we can play
Bishop G7 take C5
and okay the position is extremely
double-edged see this is the kind of
position I wouldn't even continue
calculating I would just assess
intuitively the position as being super
double edged but double edged is good
like that's kind of what we want and
already I would just go for it like we
don't even have to look too deeply for
other options I would just take E5
but there are some very pretty tactics
there some of you are noticing actually
there's a crazy move assuming we get
this position
so there is Queen D4 check as many of
you are indicating
but after Queen E4 check let's go Knight
G4 Rook takes F7 Queen D4 check King H1
is a critical position and there you
might ah well we've got Knight F2 check
winning the queen but no and I've
pointed this out before when you make a
discover check you want to make sure
that the piece that you are quote
unquote discovering the check against
cannot itself move away and capture the
piece that's delivering the check so
you're discovering a check against the
queen but the queen itself is able to
capture the Knight that's giving the
check
does that make sense a very common
source of blunders
but here's the thing if you think about
it Rook takes F7 Queen D4 checking H1
why is white able to capture on F2 well
it's because of that pesky Rook on F7
that's guarding the queen so we come up
with the idea when the distance between
two pieces is large there are a range of
tactics that I call interception tactics
they're not quite interference it's
where you literally intercept a
particular piece with another piece so
what move comes to mind well after Rook
takes F7 you could start with Bishop to
F6
okay if I takes then you give the check
on D4 King H1 and Knight F2 check
actually wins the queen now if the king
runs the other way King F1 then you have
Knight G4 to E3 check also winning the
queen but not Knight takes H2
the same reason Queen takes H2 but it's
all a moot point we'll explore that
after the game our opponent has taken a
different approach 94.
all right well clearly we should
probably take the pawn on E5 okay that's
pretty clear to me the big question is
what should we take it with well I like
the look of Knight takes C5 because it
comes with Tempo and the Knight on G4 is
far from safe a more adventurous move is
Bishop takes E5 I also like the look of
that notice that Knight takes C5 is not
a threat because we'll pick up pick off
the Knight with a check on D4
so both options are possible yours
really depends on a risk tolerance here
I'm going to take a second to think
about this
no I actually like Bishop takes C5
and there are some more um subtle
positional considerations that come into
play here
on the other hand Bishop takes E5 Rook
takes F7
wait a second
wait a second there's a cool idea
oh my God there's so much promise in
this position
okay I might have seen an even more
powerful Improvement
there there there there
gosh these lines get crazy
now I Bishop E5 Rook F7 Queen D4 check
yeah I think that works I think there's
a very important check on D4 in that
position
and I think for that reason we should
play Bishop takes E5
and again you're watching this and
probably thinking like well I'm confused
like what are you saying and what are
what are these lines and again I
literally was calculating I'm not able
to always express it on the spot that's
what the post game analysis is for
but there's a positional component to
this move and then a tactical component
to this move the positional component
comes into play if white plays the move
H3 you should ask yourself here what is
White's strongest piece well it's
probably the Knight the Knight is the
only piece that's centralized so what I
want to do after H3 is just to drop the
Knight back to F6 and eliminate White's
strongest piece and if you keep
calculating after Knight takes F6 EF or
Bishop takes F6 white is left with a
bishop on C1 that's undeveloped and not
only is it undeveloped but it's sort of
tied down to the B2 Pawn so we leave
ourselves with a much Superior Bishop in
a simplified position
okay
um
now H3 we can also give a check on D4
first to avoid Knight takes C5 and then
go Knight F6 maybe that's more accurate
um
but there's also some tactics here you
have to once again calculate Rook takes
F7
and after Rook takes F7 there is this
check that we can give on D4 our
opponent takes on C5 whoa
that's I think a blunder
but we have to be very careful here
which piece do we check on D4 with who
can tell me which piece do we deliver
this check with because one move is
tempting but wrong
the bishop is correct the bishop is
correct why so what do I see here well
the Knight on G4 is what we call a type
2 undefended piece it's only protected
by one other piece what piece is it
protected by well it's protected by the
queen so in your mind you should always
think of what roles do the pieces have
what roles are they playing and you want
to make sure that you're not giving a
piece too many roles well the queen has
the role of protecting the Knight
if you go Queen D4 check white just goes
King H1 and then if you take the Knight
you have removed the defender on your
own Knight and white can take on G4 with
check the bishop has no current role we
can give it a roll its role is now going
to be to pick up the Knight
now there's a really cool idea here for
white which perhaps our opponent is
banking on and that's the move Bishop C1
to E3 our opponent might make this move
I hope he doesn't resign because this
has been a really interesting game
so what is the purpose of Bishop E3 well
it's to intercept the check while also
protecting the Knight so wrong would be
that to then take the Knight on C5
because that Bishop on E3 will recapture
now after Bishop E3 does anybody see the
win black as a force to win there and
it's a cool little maneuver it's a cool
little idea
you basically replace one piece with the
other piece
yeah very nice Malcolm Tucker definitely
deserves a sub for that one Bishop E3 we
take it
and then the bishop is replaced to the
queen and we managed to keep our Knight
under protection while pinning The Rook
there the queen has two roles and it
fulfills both of them successfully now
obviously here you do not want to go
Knight F2 check maybe some of you are
thinking just because of Rook takes F2
that would be bad no it's time to claim
our prize and take the Knight and
convert our extra piece
now I'm expecting our opponent to either
take the pawn on F7 although it's a
little bit too late for that or to play
the move H3 and you should start
thinking about how you can meet H3
effectively
so
we've won a piece but this is actually a
chance for us to practice accurate
technique because the game is not over
there's a lot still going on where king
is not totally safe
and it's important not to get a over
excited and B
overwhelmed it should remain very
disciplined and understand what the
priorities are
now if the opportunity for a queen trade
presents itself
and it's a queen trade that does not
give anything away then we'll probably
take it I've talked about what I call
the one piece threshold rule
and the one piece threshold rule just
says that if you are up a piece or more
then you should seriously consider a
queen trade as a way of simplifying your
task if you are up less than a piece if
you're up two pawns or one Pawn
typically the strategy of trading off
all of the pieces is a lot less
effective if that makes sense
Bishop F4 our opponent develops this
piece
and now we have many many ways that we
can play this obviously but let's try to
diagnose
the biggest issues in our position and
fix them so to me the most annoying
thing about Black's position is that the
Knight on G4 is kind of stuck in The
Ether it's a little bit unprotected now
some of you then might say well let's
play Knight F6 but no the Knight on G4
itself is a very active piece it's
completely paralyzing White's entire
kingside so let's make a prophylactic
move to remove that headache once and
for all yeah simply H5 a move that I
pointed out earlier H5
what's great about this move is that if
white plays H3 we don't have to react
because HGH is another fishing hook idea
okay now what other elements of the
position could we fix well this bishop
on F4 is annoying me a little bit
because it's restricting the mobility of
Black's King
there is the move like D4 here and you
have to be very careful about let's say
a rook left to C3 so one subsequent move
that comes to mind is to play Bishop C5
back to D6 and just get rid of this darn
Bishop
also E5 yeah E5 is a great idea although
not anymore because E5 blunders the pawn
although you can still play it you can
still play it in trade
but if you really wanted to achieve E5
we have a very classy move here this is
a high class move
right you shouldn't abandon ideas just
because you run into an obstacle E5
doesn't work
well you might say let's play rookie
eight but there is a much better way to
prepare the movie 5. generally you
should prepare things with the piece of
lowest value if you can prepare
something with a pawn it's often better
than preparing it with a piece pawns are
really really good at helping other
pawns move forward
so as all of you are pointing out
excellent job F6 is the move and as a
good bonus you're also threatening G5
Fork
F6 is a multi-purpose move and but the
main idea is to play E5 and shut this
bishop down put it out of commission and
give our King a little bit of breathing
room so that there's no Shenanigans with
you know some sort of ridiculous Rook
left or or a check on C3 which otherwise
could be very dangerous
okay so we're very methodical
and we're identifying things in the
position that we can easily fix and then
we're fixing it
yeah white is no moves I mean this is
the effect that these types of moves
have on people like white literally has
just no moves
because this is a threat
you know we're just taking the air out
of the building for white completely
no we we never played King B8 we never
got around to it it was just a move that
I had pointed out as a hypothetical way
to improve
but this this is over F6 is just a
game-winning move just it just shuts
everything down
the store is closed
the move speaks for itself basically by
and large
by and large the move speaks for itself
yeah unfortunately this was a little bit
anti-climactic like Knight takes C5 is
is really an unfortunate move but we're
still at the level where
a lot of players they're not able to
handle like super chaotic positions or
positions I wouldn't call this a chaotic
position I'd call this a highly charged
position or a position with a lot of
tactical tension and tactical tension
creates
the possibility the higher possibility
of a blunder because there's a lot more
to keep track of and there's a lot more
that's hanging and your brain often just
short circuits in these situations
Bishop E3 speaking of shorts are okay
obviously this move just gives up
another exchange uh what should we take
on E3 with well we can take with either
piece it literally does not matter we
can take with the Knight we can take
with the bishop I like taking with the
bishop to keep this queen shut out as
long as possible
we're also tempting light into playing
H3 but okay anyways okay just making
sure take C3
and at this point the job is virtually
done okay again remember that when when
you reach a position like this or you're
up a full Rook for no compensation
there's going to be
a million ways that you can convert the
advantage so if you're trying to watch
and learn try to have in mind the high
level ideas rather than the individual
moves because the individual moves don't
really matter that much here so in order
to be safe I want to solve the last
remaining problem of our position which
is just the fact that you know the King
on C8 is a little bit Airy it's a little
bit Airy I don't want to have to deal
with a headache of a check on C4 or a
rook lift so I love the move Queen D4
yeah Queen D4 is probably what I'd play
in a classical game
but the Magnus move is definitely just
King back to B8 I love Queen D4 though
Queen D4 is such a nice move
because it just eliminates I mean you're
attacking B2 and you're offering a queen
trade
so I like Queen D4 and I like King B8
you know both moves are possible okay
we'll play concrete I know more people
are suggesting Queen D4 so we're gonna
go for it of course what you have to be
careful about here is the is the
response Rook to E4
and there you have to see that after
Queen takes B2 the king is actually
totally safe on C8 because there was a
check on C4 but the king would run to be
at Queen E1
okay it is not worth allowing Rook take
C7 let's shut down all of White's
remaining counter play E5 right the move
we wanted to play a little bit earlier
now it's time for it now these two
pieces are just biting on granite
so if white plays C3 then we drop our
Queen back to B6 continuing to operate
with tempo and then we'll probably pile
up on that D3 pawn and finally crash
through
bathtub formation here nicely done this
is from uh straight from the pawn and
game video this is the bathtub formation
of course it doesn't matter I mean it's
not a pawn end game
yeah the fact that the queen is
protected doesn't matter white can't
really attack it that easily
but this is the the downside of these
long speedrun games that you know the
game is over we're just chilling
but hopefully you're not too bored
Rook E4 well
I see
no real reason not to take on B2 there
is a little trap there we have to be
actually a little bit careful Queen
takes B2 Rook to B4 okay watch out Queen
takes B2 Rook to B4
and you can't take on C2 because the
Rook moves over to C4 with a fork and
the pawn on D3 is still alive
so we can take the pawn but in response
to Rook before you're just gonna have to
take the pawn on A2
and again since we've decided to play
this very concretely I would point out
two things why am I not scared how do I
know that let's say the check on C3
isn't scary well first of all there
isn't even a hypothetical mating
construction right there's no way for
white to get rid of the B7 Pawn
so the King on B8 is always going to be
safe as long as you can keep the B7 Pawn
protected the second thing is that
White's back rank was terribly weak so I
know that anytime the queen moves away I
basically have back rank me okay now we
can take another Pawn but even more
clinical let's crash through let's let's
just get down to business here what's
the move that shows our opponent we mean
business
excellent guys all getting it Rook to C8
forcing white to you know
you know what or get off the pot either
trade Rooks or move the Rook away and
allow us to take C2 linking up the queen
and the rook and setting the precursor
for Queen trade now our opponent's
probably gonna go Queen E4
and you can never ever ever relax in
these situations you always have to
watch for mate threats I know it sounds
very simple but just keep any time
you're let's say up a rook up a queen
remind yourself to go through the mental
checklist on every move is my opponent
threatening Checkmate okay are there any
weak squares that I need to keep track
of now what's the simplest way to play
here already we should be looking for
Queen traits right because by the peace
threshold rule your upper Rook so a
queen trade would make things much
easier and if you look for a queen tree
you will find one we start with a check
this is a check
King moves up and that pawn on E5 is
really the hero no mouse slipping you
check F4 and you force the queen trade
that's it and now the rest is obvious
without too much commentary
and our opponent says GG thank you
yeah very nice
very nice
okay
um
let's analyze
so we are going to use chess base I
think to take a look at some Grand Prix
attack Theory
um I'm gonna pull up chess base 17 which
hopefully will work
so we have stockfish here
um and the move that we
that I recommended is G6 now
when I said that G6 has no downside it
was a bit of a lie there is a move here
that white could try and this is a very
principled idea
this is by the way also the reason why a
lot of players don't go G6 here right
you might say well if you're a dragon
player why don't people go G6 more often
why do people play Knight C6 and allow
the rosalimo which is a huge line right
why not just go G6 well the reason
partially is because there's this line
where white plays Queen takes D4 and you
can see how scary this looks right
you've got to go Knight F6 and now White
follows through with E5 but according to
Theory this particular line is
considered to be equal you can see stock
which is eval is equal and that's
actually the truth this gets very
theoretical I won't delve into this
because right now we're looking at the
same position but with the Knight on C3
rather than F3 so let's say talk intakes
D4 Knight to F6
Knight to F6
um
there are some games in the database
here Carlson had this against Yankton in
Blitz
but apparently this is not so dangerous
for black Carlson played Bishop E3
Carlson played Bishop B3
and you basically get like a dragon type
position 17 games in the database
Duda played D6
okay probably doesn't matter F3 Bishop
G7 so you almost get like a
transposition into some sort of weird
dragon-like position Carlson played
Knight G2
and Judah played this weird move Bishop
CT sequel developing the bishop but
walking right into Knight F4
so strange move and now white is
threatening to ruin black structure that
was a bad move by Duda this is a Blitz
game
so correct according to the engine here
would have been
would have been to play Queen A5 which
is a very sensible move and you
basically get this super double-edged
position
uh and already the engine likes Bishop
six it says white is slightly better but
you know I would play this with black I
think this is sufficiently double edged
and you know somebody who had the white
pieces would have to know all of this
and feel confident in the super tactical
position King B1 Rook C pretty easy play
for black here
so you can dig around here on your own
but clearly this is not a refutation
so D4 and queen takes D4 you should be
aware of
I also point out sorry that the movie E5
is not dangerous here
why because black is the
counter-attacking move Knight C6
basically the queen has to move and keep
contact with the E5 and it's very
awkward Queen E3 Knight G4 wins the pawn
right
if Queen F4
then black is not a tribe don't be
afraid to put your knight on the rim in
such positions
and now look at this this you'll like
this bishop G7
this looks like a blunder who can tell
me why who can tell me why Bishop G7
looks like a blunder here this is a
valuable idea to remember
it's because of G4 winning the Knight
but after G4 there is the move D5 and
this is why I love the Sicilian
now you're like oh my God what's going
on here well if I takes on Passat then
the Knight can drop back and White's
position is in shambles
and if white plays Knight takes D5 then
Bishop takes G4 the queen is overloaded
it has to defend the Knight but if it
takes the bishop then we take the Knight
and White's position is collapsing with
minus four because everything is falling
and just look at White's position
so this is a valuable idea to remember
Knight H5 and D5 you wouldn't be able to
find this without preparation and if
white plays Knight F3 then we are in
time to contest that E5 upon we go D6
and again G4 here there is even the move
F5
forcing this Pawn to move out of the way
or if on passant then black recaptures
with the Knight so brilliant ideas F5
and D5 and Black's position is just so
rich here so long story short D4 is a
move
um but unless white plays it like Magnus
it's nothing to be super afraid of so
let's
um continue the analysis
well I am the boxer you're saying this
is above my head but if you could
specifically tell me which move doesn't
make sense I'll explain it more slowly
I'll explain it more thoroughly so if
you're watching and you're like a
beginner I understand that some of this
will seem overwhelming but I'm really
trying to break down every move so it
makes perfect sense
um and if it doesn't I'm happy to repeat
it or rephrase it there's nothing
embarrassing about going at your own
pace
all right so G6 our opponent played the
Grand Prix attack Bishop G7 Knight F3
Knight C6 and Bishop to B5 which is a
very topical move
which is a very topical move if you look
at reference the main line in this
position is Bishop B5 it is now
considered the most popular move and it
scores well so it's a very important
move to know the engine does like Knight
D4 the fish likes Knight D4
and here our opponent let's see if he
goes down the main line yes he does
castles is the main line over a thousand
games
so we played Knight takes B5
so let's take a look at it
Knight takes B5
okay one second I don't know what's
going on
Nico please stop
I think that's Nico
Nico please stop it's making the
annoying sound
thank you so Knight takes B5 isn't
necessarily the best move
but I actually love the engine's
recommendation here I love the engine's
recommendation here of D5 this is a move
you would never play unless you knew it
was good
unless you knew it was good now it looks
like a blunder right I mentioned during
the game that this move is a blunder
because of e65 173 games in the database
but after a six
now obviously Queen takes D5 everybody
should see why this is wrong because it
wonders of work okay but you play A6
Knight C3 and Knight F6 and you simply
win the pawn back
you simply win the panda and you win the
pawn back and you with interest right
black as the bishop pair this Pawn is
sticking out like a sore thumb you're
controlling the F5 Square
so I love the move D5 and it's been
played
and in order to not be worse it it
appears that white needs to play E5 but
when the center closes in the Grand Prix
attack you can actually play the move d4
what is the purpose of this move to
restrict the White Knight and prevent it
from coming back to C3 and after A6
you're going to force the Knight onto
the super awkward A3 Square
okay white has to play the engine move
C3 I think most humans would play D3
there are some games in the database
here a693 and as is very typical in such
positions when you see this structure F4
E5 you should immediately be thinking of
the light squares what light squares
well the light squares that are around
the pawns are all very weak and you can
exploit it by developing the Knight to
H6 don't be so you know this is a
typical move because also the Knight is
heading for F5 and perhaps later for E3
and if black Clay is for example H3
um you can play the engine move B5
restricting the Knight and you should
never be afraid of this situation
because look at how weak white is on the
king's side the king is wide open Queen
D5 is coming and later in the game you
could play the move F6 and open up a
little pathway for the Knight to go back
to F7
so the important conclusion from this
analysis and you can see that the engine
actually doesn't necessarily think that
Knight takes Bishop is the best move
um
but I'm I don't know A6 is the engine
top recommendation right now at depth
30. so maybe it's worth investigating I
will leave that to you to take a look at
the move Asics I really like this idea
though 1965 xb5 D5 it's simple it's easy
to remember and most importantly it's
very testing right this is how you
choose lines it's super testing because
white already has a chance to be much
worse 172 games when he takes D5 most
people even GMS did take the spot and
that's a mistake
right white can also play the move to D3
but here I love the engine
recommendation A6 Knight C3 and now you
take it
and then you take it and then you go
into a slightly better end game
two games in the database
white is worse white as weak pawns and
uh we don't care about giving away the
fiancado bishop because it's an end game
right
does that make sense
so no matter what white does I like
Black's position
and our move was D6 we played a popular
move
but after our opponent's response D3 I
think the position is probably about
equal
and after we played Knight F6 our
opponent responded with Queen E1 still
38 games in the database and you can see
here that the engine is not the biggest
fan of this for black
and I have a feeling that after Bishop
G4 uh we were already worse yeah Bishop
G4 is kind of inaccurate it's a novelty
and already you know the position is
slightly dubious so let's transition now
from chessbase to chess.com because the
sort of part of the game where we use
the engine has elapsed now we go into
the middle game and that I'd like to
analyze without the engine unless there
are any opening questions this is what
opening analysis looks like right and of
course we left some stuff out what did
we leave out well we didn't analyze the
entire Grand Prix attack there's Bishop
C4 very major line and here are the
response to Z6 followed by Knight G7
this is the classic botvinic setup
and of course we left out no not this
move alternatives to castles right white
can take the Knight for example but this
is all bad for for white and you can
analyze this on your own with an engine
um I will show you the basic idea of the
Grand Prix through the lens of the game
continuation so let's remove the engine
let's switch back to our chess.com
screen
I apologize that this was you know a
drag or boring but remember this is an
opening speed run so I am trying to give
you as much opening knowledge as
possible and really help you build a
repertoire from scratch if that's what
you desire
okay
so
94 castles take Stakes d63 Knight F6
um Queen E1
and
um in order for you to understand the
basic idea of the Grand Prix let us
consider the move Castle short
where is the queen going in the Grand
Prix well it's going to H4 why is it
going to H4 well again to illustrate the
idea let's take a sample line let's say
black goes here
attacking the Knight wide goes back and
let's say black starts attacking on the
queen side and you go B5
okay who can tell me what White's next
move is and this is a terrifying move I
can show you right off the top of my
head I can do a search for a thousand
games that have ended precisely in this
way okay in various versions right not
not necessarily exactly in this way but
in in in in very similar ways let me
actually run a little search
here we go this is the game between two
pretty decent players now watch Grand
Prix attack black plays it very
similarly is actually following our game
basically this is literally not exactly
now watch bang F5
black does exactly what we think A6 I'm
gonna start preparing so it's like Bang
bang Bishop H6 this is why you play F5
fgh Bang
and now the beautiful combination this
is one of the typical ideas in the Grand
Prix does anybody see it
this is gorgeous you you will enjoy this
a lot Rook takes F6 is correct
now black has two recaptures if he takes
F6 then it's all very easy Bishop G7
and it's mate whichever way you take
it's either made on H7 or made on h8 but
what happens after Bishop F6 does
anybody see the move here yes Bishop to
G7 and black resigns because it's the
same problem if you take the bishop you
get mated on H7 if you take the Knight
you get mated on h8
so this is just one very very simple
illustration here's another one
and I'm only trying to find games with
you know serious players
this is a completely different game
but this is the beauty of studying
openings carefully because once you
acquaint yourself with the ideas you
realize how repetitive these openings
can actually be
two thousand right panessa against
panessa I wonder if they're siblings
Henry panesso is a Colombian I am
here you go again right now Bishop takes
C6 this dime white gives away the light
squared Bishop straight away
um
now watch
Queenie one
what does white do Bang
Bang
H3 slow move Bang
and if you're paying attention you
already know Rook F6 Bishop F6 Bishop G7
and black resigned completely different
game ends in exactly the same way so
this is just one micro illustration of
how dangerous this attack can be the
Grand Prix attack can be and this is why
I was terrified of Castle in kingside
okay
um I could show you a million other
ideas but this is just a little flavor
of of how dangerous the Grand Prix can
be
and this exact thing could have happened
in this position right F5 and remember
that g takes F5 does not help right it
actually makes things worse because now
the king is even weaker
and again Knight G5 is coming and
another idea that you should keep in
mind
is that after Knight G5 there is this
typical concept of going Knight to D5
this is not just a Grand Prix attack
idea
it's a deflection it's a simple
deflection
what are you deflecting well you're
deflecting the knight from the H7 Pawn
so almost all Grand Prix attacks that
end successfully end in a Checkmate on
H7
this is why
I did not want to Castle and touch that
with a 10-foot pole this is why we did
all of what we did Bishop G4
Queen H4 and queen to D7 Knight comes
back to C3 and again why did I have to
take on F3 because here I was worried
about the move Knight G5
and apparently according to the engine
that black is fine and the reason black
is fine this is what I missed Rook df8
H3 who can tell me what Black's best
move is here who sees a little detail
that I missed
oh it's a beautiful it's H6
counter-attacking the knight
counter-attack in the night
and if white takes black takes and with
the H file open this is just over
this is over Red Rover The Bishop's
coming in
so white has to move the Knight back
and now we have a brilliant engine move
G5 blast it all open
takes takes double attack on the queen
queen takes G5 Now watch how the engine
plays
just Bishop B6 is good but even Bishop
takes H3 is good
Rook fg8 setting up threats against the
queen
now we drive The Rook up to H5 the queen
is forced onto an awkward Square If It
Moves back Bishop H6 another discovery
and now black is just squashing white
like a bug here
this is how strong I mentioned this
right black can actually attack on the
king side as well which is quite ironic
but this is just the flavor of that
anyways I did not see them move H6
that's why I decided it uh prudent to
trade on F3 first probably a uh an
inaccuracy oops sorry
a bug there
so we took on F3 and then we castled now
I think white is slightly better here
but position is probably more or less
equal okay
E5 is already a mistake it's premature
why does opening up the center without
being ready for it because white is
underdeveloped why doesn't have his
Bishop out and the white king is
actually much weaker than black skin the
moment this move was played I was
already considering ideas related to
Queen D4 what should white have done
well the move that I was a little bit
concerned with is F5 I think F5 is a
good move to open up a longer diagonal
for the bishop I think another good move
the engine proposes Bishop D2 just get
the bishop out
why not Bishop E3 because that runs into
Knight G4
so Bishop D2 I think is a very good move
we would have played King B8
white can play Rook B1 to prepare the
move before opening up the B5 we do the
same thing on the king side so the
position becomes very double-edged the
engine is giving like 0.3.4 which is
totally reasonable but our King is
obviously much safer here than on the
king side
yeah King H1 absolutely I would consider
a move like King H1 but the problem with
King H1 is that I think we're kind of
running into H6 and G5 remember if the H
file opens that this is going to be
counterproductive
but I don't want to bug ourselves down
too deeply into this position because
it's just a complicated position right
and you can dig around on your own here
E5 I want to share some of my analysis
here and of course the topical move is
Rook takes F7
now just to repeat what I said Queen D4
King H1 and Knight F2 wins the queen no
it doesn't because if Queen takes F2 so
the idea that comes to mind is Bishop G7
to F6
but amazingly this doesn't appear to
work
because if you keep calculating King F1
93 check Bishop takes E3 we win the
queen right but it's not the end of the
story because what does white have in
return for the queen well a bunch of
stuff white has this Monster Pawn on E7
white actually has two pawns total and
two minor pieces so watch material
advantage is not that vast but here's
the critical detail as the engine
proposes here white has the cold-blooded
move King to G1
and all of this hinges on a critical
tactic who can tell me what happens
after Rook takes C7
type 2 undefended peace what's defending
it the Queen We chase away the queen
with the simple move G3 the queen has
nowhere along this diagonal to stay to
keep in contact with the Rook black is
lost
black is lost
so this is just amazing these lines are
crazy and according to the engine white
is better after King Juan because black
is just paralyzed yeah you've got the
extra Queen but your Rooks are totally
tied down White's got a bunch of these
active moves that he can play well I
guess not Ricky won but Rook to F1 and
Knight D5 and C4 and
it's amazing but here's what else is
amazing in this position white has an
unbelievable move that forces a draw
it's an unbelievable move white doesn't
even have to give away the queen
think about it
it's a ridiculous engine move and you
will just this will knock your socks off
Bishop to E3
Queen takes you through and now King to
H1
and sorry to get so excited about that I
just think these are cool lines
now you're like this is smothered mate
right I learned about this this is
smothered mate but it's not because of
the queen on H4
right you actually cannot deliver
smothered maid here and you CA this is
why you can't just blindly apply
tactical Concepts you actually have to
match them to the specific position on
the board now you might say well no
problem am I really saying that black
has no effective discoveries here that's
exactly what I'm saying because if you
play Knight takes D3 you can win a pawn
but that's the most you can win where
are you gonna go 94 big deal King H1 if
you try some Shenanigans then white gets
The Rook into the game and takes C7 and
this is no good
so there's actually no effective
Discovery other than to repeat moves
um
you can say insane so this was the wrong
idea Bishop F6 is the wrong idea the
correct move is actually a very Zen move
very Zen move again it's the principle
of trading away your opponent's
strongest piece it's such a powerful
idea white has only one active piece and
it's The Rook so we traded just go work
Cafe
deceptively simple move
and of course you have to see that here
you have Queen divorce but this is easy
to calculate and this is this is made
and here of why tries Bishop E3 well
then obviously the situation has changed
and after Knight F2 King G1 you have
this Rook on f8 and Knight D1 leads to
Maiden 2.
okay so this is pretty straightforward
so Rook Cafe is incredibly strong it's
actually winning for blackrook hf8 white
has to take it
and now you simply take back and just
look at the the storm clouds that have
gathered around White's king queen D4 is
essentially Unstoppable there's just
nothing that white can do against this
threat
and the game is over the game is over
so just the power of these ideas our
opponent of course plays 94 and Bishop
takes C5
and um
yeah our opponent blundered on the spot
with Knight takes C5 but of course the
move that I was expecting here well
first of all if Rook takes F7
here I was actually planning to go Rook
f8 either Rook hf8 or df8 and um again
the game is over probably more accurate
is to play Rook DFA to keep H7 defended
and according to the engine Rook back to
F3 is the only move but now Knight takes
H2 is very strong and this is like -3
because this is coming in and we're up a
pawn and the king is weak
this is not worth analyzing too deeply
black is just overwhelmingly better
um so I think the white is not much that
he can do here he's already down a pawn
and uh we're also attacking so this was
not good H3 I was planning to go Knight
F6
um but it occurred to me that this is a
blunder because white can play Knight
65.
um so instead we should play the
preliminary Intermezzo Bishop D4
and now you can go back to F6 but even
better is to play the move F5 just
counter-attacking then I get it out of
E4
now this is also overwhelming
um so the idea after Bishop to E3 was to
play Bishop take C3 check replacement
idea take stakes and the queen replaces
the bishop Queen D4 and now the queen
defends the Knight and attacks The Rook
black wins a full Rook
okay
so there's just nothing that white can
do white is forced to lose a piece and
the rest I think we're going to present
without uh too much analysis H5 to
solidify that of course the winning move
is F6 this is really the the move that
ends all of White's resistance uh
because everything is coming and white
ends up giving away The Rook we take it
and the rest was very straightforward
the last thing I'll say if we fast
forward a little bit Rook B4 would have
been the last try if you're on the white
side in these positions this just shows
you that you can always set a trap
always and of course Queen C2 Rook C4
check would needlessly complicate the
test black is still winning by the way
black is still winning because we've got
a billion puns but why would you ever do
that why would you not just take on A2
and win the game and all of these checks
are not dangerous so just go King B8
and remember it's not possible to just
like force a Perpetual that's not how it
works you can just hide the king away
and then block with the queen and you're
good to go
okay so that was actually deeper
analysis than I had expected in that
game I know I went really kind of down
under the surface in the opening in the
middle game but I hope you really
enjoyed uh that analysis I that was
really really fun for me
uh unless there are any questions I
think it's time for us to call it a
night
so if you're new to my stream and you
want to support you've got a patreon
I've got twitch obviously all subs are
greatly appreciated but the most
important thing is to subscribe on
YouTube if you like the content as we
try to hit 400 000 Subs by next year
that's the goal we're trying to grow at
a very modest pace of a hundred thousand
per year and maybe one day one day in
the far future hit 500K
uh so that's the goal so have a
fantastic MLK weekend everybody and I
will see you very soon bye
[Music]